can i give you a compliment many times
when i'm feeling down
what i do is i go on uh youtube yeah
yeah yeah
and i watch you on various talk shows
and i have a good laugh
oh that's nice you're a very good talk
show guest
i believe disney world well there you go
down in florida you ever go there i've
never been there well you don't have
your
baron not barren but you're right i'm
trying that's right i'm
i'm barren i'm infertile and possibly
have children
you hate me now because there's stuff
about your testicles
[Applause]
you know what's a funny thing about talk
shows because you know i've done them
for
20 years and 20 years ago when i went on
a talk show
you would talk and then it would just
evaporate into nothingness
and now it's forever right i have a uh
where i'm saying how cosby is the
greatest guy in the world you know what
i mean
they don't know what year it's from yeah
or anything like that
i'm not exactly sure what brought you to
being a stand-up comic because you
described like even in school you
weren't the class clown or anything like
that
not at all no first of all i couldn't
afford the shoes right to be the classic
and what about the red nose how much
does that cost
there was no money in the family no but
seriously you you
that's all right you can go now that was
a great line you can't do better than
that
you decide to become a comic you're
working at it and you're working i guess
it was in la at this point a johnny
carson
scout yes sees you in a club johnny
carson has already announced his uh
retirement right and johnny carson as
you know used to be able to anoint
comedians
you became instant financial success so
in my mind as he only had six months ago
i said i'm going to be the last comedian
to be anointed by johnny carson right so
jim mccauley would come to the show you
know
he's the talent scout for the tonight
show yeah yeah and then afterwards
one time he came up he said the first
time he said i didn't like you but
i was really drunk great it's my whole
life
one time i'm on stage i look over he's
necking with a girl
oh my good god so then finally he goes
uh
he goes listen you're a jay comic
and i go well what does that mean
because jay letter was doing it monday
night
guest host so he's like yeah you're the
you're
more of a jay comic then whatever that
means
meaningless nonsense right so i go no no
i think i'm a johnny comic that's what
all my friends say you know
he's like no jay and then he's like oh
besides and then
for some reason whispers that he goes
jay will be taken over you know i know
it was in the paper last year
we saw that yeah
he said if you do good on jay johnny
will watch at home
you know which again again an audition
there was a lie like
you know johnny's at home hey i wonder
how jay's doing yeah johnny
johnny by the way want the time off he
wasn't sitting at home watching the
tonight show
right he was on a a yacht with bombastic
bushkin and his wife and his beautiful
wife alexis i ended up doing my first on
dave and that was bad well there was a
real bond
letterman was your guy letterman was my
career guy i mean he once said if we
could have norman every week we would
have
and then he said the ultimate compliment
there may be people as funny as norm but
i don't know anybody funnier
that had a floor right yeah no yeah that
meant something to me that'll buckle
your knees
ladies and gentlemen could be the
funniest man in the world we got the
paperwork on that
and he always called you norm mcdonald
like he like he exaggerated your name
whatever it was but you went on there
and you did really well you picked up on
that yeah it would always be norm
mcdonald is here and i'm like old
macdonald is here
i don't know what it was norm mcdonald
norm
mcdonald norma mcdonald it was such a
genuine moment
when you were the last stand-up comic to
perform on dave's show
sometimes with the way you are the way
you carry yourself i don't see you as an
overly emotional person
and i was really moved honestly when
unless you were the last comic to stand
up comic to perform on letterman you
went out and did a set and then you
turned to dave and you said a couple of
heartfelt things
and and you were moved to tears and i
was really moved by that because
i didn't know you felt that way about
letterman and
you were so complimentary to him and you
kind of let down the
the comedy thing which i thought was so
strong because when you're doing
stand-up
you know it's false by nature yes
and then all of a sudden you kind of
opened up as to who you were
for real yeah and you showed letterman
how much you cared about him
i'd just like to say i know that uh mr
letterman is uh
uh not for the marquis
and he has uh he has no truck for the
sentimental
but if something is true it is not
sentimental
and i say in truth i love you
and it was really genuinely moving and i
think it's because you feel like wow
well also it was accidental i didn't go
out there with
with that place no but you wanted to say
something i wanted to say something i
didn't know quite it was
it wasn't that right um there was some
stupid thing i'd
written you know that sounded just
written and fake and then when i started
to say it i was like i was
gonna sound i'll just talk you know did
letterman say anything to you afterwards
after the show was over or was it there
was no discussion of it he whispered in
my ear or something
then you want to keep private private
he said something to you that that you
that was special uh
toward you yeah yeah very special very
special because
and you know um the night after that bob
dylan who was also
holds a special place in my life was
also on the show
those three days were emotional
very emotional for me yeah as much as
saturday night live
holds memories for me and david
letterman although i have no backstage
uh
experience with him at all right um just
things he's talked to me about in
between commercials and stuff like that
i i always felt so uh so close i felt i
i really felt like that
they talked about father figures that he
was my father figure
oh my god
very funny norm and thank you thank you
for everything
thank you norm mcdonald ladies and
gentlemen
that was very sweet norman good night
everybody